in the dressing room something happens
while I'm getting ready once I start
putting my makeup on I turn from this
male to female and that is amazing for
me
my name is Cassandra exotic oh I am a
professional wrestler I've been
wrestling for 28 years I'm an exotic
Oulu teller which is a flamboyant a
wrestler with glamour and style
I always knew I was different I remember
when I was in second grade I think I was
like 7 or 8 years old and I already knew
I was I was gay I was taught that I
couldn't be gay I couldn't act this way
I couldn't dress this way I couldn't
talk this way because I was gonna burn
in hell when I was first called to be an
exotic car I was like wow freedom this
weighted that I've been carrying for
years was just like melted down
rhinestones rhinestones glow-in-the-dark
I started using the pantyhose
the makeup the bathing suits rhinestone
feathers and Boas and all that because I
wanted to be different and that was the
scariest moment but when I saw the
audience and the fans how they took me
in they were just like wow look at him
her.she I feel like a woman inside and
then it's like this is me and that
transformation is beautiful
something happens when I get out of the
dressing room to the ring I'm still
looking like a woman I'm looking
flamboyant and then once I step in the
ring my macho sigh kicks in
I might gotta be ready for the fight all
my cuddle matches and mostly all of our
matches has been against men masked man
like G stars homophobe eggs and I've
always been tricked myself its Lucha
Libre not a beauty parlor even though it
looks like it sometimes today I can tell
you that being gay has been a gift from
God to me and I understand that so
that's why you Charlie Villa has always
been one of my biggest medications I
don't think I will ever leave me
calibrate this is what I've done all my
life
you